[Musique]
le lundi vous en avez désormais
l'habitude c'est la chronique sport de
miquel et demi d'euros bonsoir notre
journaliste au sport de cette rédaction
commence michael cette chronique par du
football c'est ça avant de vous parler
du match de versailles contre les ulis
en nationale 3 je vous propose de revoir
cette action ont joué la deuxième
période de cette rencontre et c'est le
moment qu'a choisi un jour des ulis pour
commettre cette faute
regardez grégory les deux pieds sont
décollées c'est par derrière
le joueur sera évidemment expulsé est ce
qu'on appelle un attentat dans le jargon
on peut le dire on peut le dire je me
saoule autorise en tout cas un rouge
logique on n'aime pas ce genre d'actions
on préfère voir le vrai football la
johnny qui michael est ce que cette
expulsion a eu des conséquences sur le
résultat et non cette expulsion n'aura
finalement pas avantagé à versailles
quatrième match nul de la saison ce
samedi 10 novembre les versaillais n'ont
pas réussi à forcer le verrou défensif
des ulis lors de cette 9e journée de
national 3 score final à 0 à 0 malgré
une nette domination des joueurs de la
cité royale on écoute les réactions hall
a bien maîtrisé le jeu on a eu beaucoup
d'action le problème c'est qu'on manque
d'efficacité c'est simple pour nous
notamment dans la maîtrise du jeu on a
et on a été là on a la possession de
balle les actions c'est juste le but qui
manque un mois le sentiment d'avoir fait
le maximum pour pouvoir forcer la
décision en notre faveur mais mais il
nous a manqué un petit peu ce brin de
réussite ce dernier geste qui nous
aurait permis d'ouvrir le score je pense
de gagner ce match s'il attaque reste
perfectible la défense de versailles
ration l'équipe n'a encaissé que cinq
buts en huit matches disputés cette
saison une bonne défense qui pourrait
permettre à versailles de passer au 8e
tour de la coupe de france les versets
sont opposés ce dimanche 18 novembre
alès dragon un club polynésien au 7e
tour de la compétition
il y aura un certain à marama vahirua
sur la pelouse
il a 38 ans aujourd'hui les belles
heures de la d1 ce qu'on appelait à la
d1 à l'époque est aujourd'hui la lumière
ça ne nous rajeunit pas michael non pas
du tout alors également ce week-end du
rugby ah oui exactement de résultats
tout d'abord dans le championnat de
division honneur versailles et toujours
invaincus les joueurs de la cité royale
se sont imposés 23 à 3 sur le terrain du
clairement rugby club et réalise donc un
début de saison parfait avec cinq
victoires en cinq matches au classement
les versailles et compte maintenant 24
points et s'envole au classement
il compte cinq points d'avancé surmonter
son prochain match dimanche prochain sur
le terrain de la nuit en fédérale 2 l
équivalent de la 4e division nationale
plaisir a réalisé le gros coup du
week-end les plaisirs en battu ce
dimanche à l'extérieur charteau sixième
du classement
score final 19 à 17 une performance qui
permet aux yvelinois de remonter à la
10e place du classement avec 13 points
et de s'éloigner un peu de la zone de
relégation
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile contre l'équipe dur
merci michael plein d'autres résultats
encore dans votre 7,8 sport c'est à
suivre juste après ce journal